so I joined the Oklahoma City Police
Department 1974 when I retired in 2008 I
was at home watching Young and the
Restless on the TV when my wife came
through there she said you will find
something to do
[Music]
back in the 1800s you get caught
stealing cattle what happened they'd
find a rope they'd find a tree in this
stamp your ticket right there
hey well you got me the rancher called
me he had yesterday morning about 10
steers that were in his Corral and he
got here yesterday afternoon they were
gone
cattle rustling is really lucrative for
the people who steal these cattle if I
steal your TV that you spent $2,000 for
I maybe get 50 bucks for it but the
cattle aren't like that
if I steal your cow I can take that cow
to the livestock market that's gonna
bring twelve fifteen hundred dollars
ahead it's quick money if you don't get
caught this tracks right here looks like
they've got out we want to stop this
kind of thing happening but what these
guys when we arrest these people when
they're stealing cattle it is not
uncommon anymore we hear it every day
the reason why is because of their
addictions to myth
you
[Music]